yeah sorry i was really excited that  because i mean this is just i mean  it's it's in the books  that's uh you don't close up the  position like this and it's also e5 is  not enough unless you have something  tangible against the king very difficult  now it's now it's lost well yeah i mean  there is a very good chance that it's  objectively lost because b takes c6  already is threat so he has nothing  better it seems like he has to give up  an exchange which is not funny at all  yep  maybe he missed this  um  i think he just strategically  missed this option that b4 b5 sometimes  there is simply positional blunders yeah  you're not in time with your counter  chances and this is what happens here i  think with black yeah knight a6 was an  opportunity  takes takes and let's see if p6 is the  move i think  though b7 is also very interesting try  and play